before we dive into more content let's
take a step back here's what you can
expect to learn in the upcoming lessons
in the first lesson we'll start by
covering how you can generate ideas and
evaluate them against each other then
you'll learn techniques for validating
your ideas so you know you're working on
a product that has a place in the market
in lesson two you'll learn about
high-level concerns for user experience
and user interaction now you won't be a
professional user experience designer by
the end of the lesson instead you'll
have a strong sense of the big questions
you need to answer about user experience
and you'll also identify common design
elements in products with a validated
idea from lesson one and the knowledge
of user experience in lesson two you'll
start to build mock-ups of your app or
website through a design sprint you'll
learn how startups get real feedback
from users in just a few days this is
the same methodology that Google
aventure uses with startup such as nest
and Blue Bottle coffee
finally in Lesson four you'll learn
about metrics so you can figure out how
to improve the product and grow the
business along the way you'll be
completing tasks related to the final
project in the end you will have gone
through the effort of generating
researching validating and testing a
mock-up of your product with users